Ich interessiere mich, glaube ich, in meinem Leben für zwei Dinge.
So, das eine sind Obstschalen und das andere ist die Schlacht von Verda.
Motten und Schmetterlinge sind relativ nah beieinander, was Körperbau, Anatomie und noch mehr Sytonyme zu dem Wort angeht.
Was ist da eigentlich los? Warum findet man Motten so scheisse, weil Schmetterlinge so cool?
Das Podcast-Ufo mit Florento Will und Stefan. Mein, du kannst doch nicht wieder dich hier komplett im Wohnzimmer breit machen. Du weisst doch, dass ich dieses Wochenende meine Verwandten eingeladen habe. Oh nein, jetzt habe ich schon meinen ganzen Basketballclub eingeladen. Och Stefan, du weisst doch. Und du weisst doch, was passiert, wenn ich den Jungs sage, dass wir hier nicht trainieren können. Aber du weisst doch auch, wie Tante Clara drauf ist und seit sie das Erbe bekommen hat, muss ich eben dafür sorgen, dass sie mich mag, weil wer weiß, wer das Erbe bekommt. Die ist immer noch nicht tot. Mal gucken, ob wir das ändern können. Gott sei Dank sind fucking Silkems tot. Gott sei Dank sind sie tot. Das würde ich persönlich ...
Sonst würdest du ihnen selber die Augen ausstechen.
Ja, mit so einem Messer rumlaufen und jedem so anstechen, im Bauch erst kurz so.
Ja, ja, erst mal schon rein.
Und dann oben in die Augen rein und dann so drehen.
Bauch, Augen, Bauch, Augen.
Und dann das Messer im Auge noch so drehen und sagen, wie findest du das, Two and a Half Men? Und dann hört man nur so Dosenlacher. Oh, ist er tot. Für immer und ewig. Aber vielleicht gibt es noch mal ein Revival, denn wir wissen, alles kommt immer wieder, egal ob du es willst. Es kommt immer wieder, auch wenn es furchtbar war. Ist das unser politischer Kommentar. Beggy Jeans waren immer schon wunder, wunderschön. Und jetzt, ich finde Beggy Jeans ganz toll, dass die jetzt da sind wieder, finde ich ganz toll. Ja, kannst du wieder deine eigenen Sachen auspacken. Und meine Proportionen sind normal. Dein Arsch sieht so gut aus wie lange nicht, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, Stefan.
Also wirklich, da will ich manchmal reinbeissen. Dankeschön. Ich bin jetzt im grossen Ausmistmodus, meine Wohnung wird aufgelöst und ich schmeisse alles weg, ich schmeisse alles weg, ich schmeisse alles weg, alles muss raus. Ich habe keinen Bock auf Umzug, ich sage Umzug wird jetzt ersetzt durch Umzug in die Müllkläranlage. wenn du verstehst, was ich meine.
Also, ich zieh kaum was um. Nee, ich versteh nicht. Nee, ich sag mal, Umzug, meine nächste Wohnung heißt Müllhalde. Du verstehst, was ich meine. Nee, du willst ja hinziehen oder was? Ich meine, dass ich einfach sehr viel wegschmeiss, anstatt es umzuziehen, weil letzten Endes hat man ja nur Müll. Das darfst du nicht sagen. Das habe ich auch mal gesagt. Ja, du hast mal gesagt, dass du eine Wii wegschmeißt. Da hast du richtig wütende Mails bekommen von Leuten, die gesagt haben, spende die Wii doch an Waisenhaus. Und man muss daran, das war im Jahre 2020 oder so, wo schon die PlayStation 8 rauskam. Aber trotzdem ist das natürlich ein völlig legitimer Kritikpunkt. aber ich werfe tatsächlich viele Bücher weg, muss ich sagen. Das sind keine kinderfreundlichen Bücher. Sind das nicht spannende Bücher, die ich noch gebrauchen könnte? Man merkt ja dann, wenn man bei so einem Umzug merkt man ja so, was hatte man für Lebensentwürfe, die kaputt gegangen sind. Ich hatte ja mal so eine intellektuelle Phase, habe gelesen, Freud, Lacan, Gizek, Hegel. Die hätte ich jetzt gerne. Und habe mir dann natürlich die Bücher mehr gekauft als gelesen, so ehrlich muss man sein. So ehrlich muss man sein. Und dann wirft man die alle weg, weil man denkt, ja, hab ich am Ende doch nicht gelesen und hab ich vielleicht auch selber ein bisschen getrogen. Und am Ende wandert davon jetzt relativ viel in Müll, einfach ungelesen auch. Und ich hab ja dann auch so Magazine irgendwie, so Nymphen, das Magazin für Psychoanalyse und so. Und man denkt sich, wer war ich, als ich das, als ich dachte, ich lese das wirklich. Und das ist, und mittlerweile, glaube ich, bin ich an dem Punkt in meinem Leben, wo man auch seine eigenen Träume begraben kann. Ich glaube, das ist ganz gesund, weil du hechelst ja im ganzen Leben gewissen Idealvorstellungen von dir hinterher. Und ich glaube, ein Punkt, an dem du einfach sagst, ich werde Hegel einfach nicht mehr lesen. Ich brauche den nicht mehr im Regal. Du hast mal, als ich dich mal gefragt habe, was dein Liebkphilosoph ist, Hegel gesagt. Ja. Also jetzt willst du mir nach, ich hatte das damals wirklich so empfunden als, ah cool, er kennt sich aus, geil. Und jetzt kommt raus, dass du mich angerogen hast? Richtig, rückblickend kann ich sagen, ich hatte nie eine Ahnung, wovon ich rede. Ich habe mich komplett durchgeblufft und ich wusste nie, worum es geht. Und eigentlich interessiert es mich auch nicht wirklich. Aber das ist ja meine These, dass es jedem so geht. Ja. Und die, die was schreiben, also jetzt im Extrembeispiel, selbst Hegel bullshetet sich nur drum. Ja. Er konnte es halt nur am besten. Ja, das kann sein. Ja. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich das, glaube ich ich beerdige und einfach sagen muss, ich werde nie ein intellektueller Typ sein, ich werde nie ein Wolfgang im Schmidt sein. Ach, du bist schon recht intellektuell. Aber so Bücher lesen und wirklich sich da hinsetzen und die durchwalzen werde ich einfach nicht. Und ich habe eine ganze Zeit lang meines Lebens einfach ein Leben gelebt, das ich selber gar nicht so gewollt und geführt habe und da nichts mitgenommen habe. Doch gewollt hast du es glaube ich schon. Ich habe es schon gewollt, aber ich stand nicht mit Herz und Seele dahinter. Ich weiss zum Beispiel noch mal, dass ich auf so einer Konferenz war in München, wo Leute Vorträge gehalten haben, unter anderem dabei Slavoj Žižek, der bekannte Kultphilosoph, um das jetzt mal abwerten zu sagen, wo natürlich alle sagen, ja, aber ich verstehe wirklich, was er meint und ich lese ja wirklich seine Bücher, für mich ist es nicht nur das Meme und so. Und dann war ich da bei einem Vortrag, habe mir das angehört, da ging es um Parallaxe und dann war ich da auch bei meinen Eltern in München zu essen und dann meinte mein Vater so, ach, du meinst, du warst bis hier so für eine Konferenz, worum geht es denn da eigentlich, so, was ist denn das? Und du, ähm, ich, ähm, also, ähm, ich war dann da und, ähm, ich weiß nicht. Und ich habe gemerkt, ich habe keine Ahnung. Also ich kann das nicht zusammenfassen, ich kann es nicht sagen. Also ich glaube nicht, dass ich gar nichts mitgenommen habe von so einem Vortrag, aber letzten Endes merkt man, nee, eigentlich ist es eine Idealvorstellung und man fühlt sich ja total cool in so einem Vortrag und denkt sich, oh, da steht jetzt dieser legendäre Intellektueller, aber man nimmt nichts nicht mit und man hat keine Ahnung. Und eigentlich alles, was man mitnimmt, ist ja ein Selbstwertgefühl, zu sagen, ich war am Wochenende da und da und ich habe das gesehen. Aber ist das ein geiler Zugang? Und ist nicht immer der Wunsch, dazuzugehören oder so zu sein, oft auch einfach ein geiler Zugang, um sich dann wirklich zu erschliessen? Absolut, ja. Und dann ist wirklich so, fake it till you make it. Ich habe ja auch, rückblickend gab es Momente auch in meinem Studium, wo ich dachte, okay krass, jetzt habe ich wirklich was verstanden und finde ich gut, aber mittlerweile zocke ich halt auch gerne World of Warcraft. Ja, aber daran bist du ja richtig gut zum Beispiel. Das ist halt dann eher meins und das ist die Frage, ab wann muss man sich selber akzeptieren und aufhören zu träumen, so das ist die Frage, ne, also da hast ja auch du auch viel dazu geschrieben und hast ja Vorträge gehalten zum Thema Träumen, ja, aber bis wann? Ja genau, es war grob überschrieben mit dem Stichwort Parallaxe und ja, ich weiß, du hast es ja auch zugehört, du weißt nicht, was du mitgenommen hast. Jedenfalls, was ich noch sagen wollte, ist, ich habe ja gerade, also ich wünschte mir solche Bücher. Also vielleicht, du bist ja ein paar Jahre älter, nicht signifikant, aber das ist schon ein, was uns trennt sind, glaube ich vier Jahre und das ist schon dieses, wenn ich jetzt was auf mein Ich von vor vier Jahren blicke, cringe ich mir auch einen zusammen. Ja, okay. Und so schaue ich immer auf dich, weißt du? Ja, ja. Also das ist immer dieser Unterschied. Und ich bin schon exakt und ich würde mich jetzt darüber freuen, diese Bücher in mein Regal zu stellen. Genau, das ist es ja am Ende. Das bin ich ja gerade. Und natürlich, du bist jetzt weiser als ich und der große Florentin und du willst sie wegwerfen, was ich schon eine krasse Geste finde, du kannst sie einfach auf die Strasse stellen. Ich bin allerdings, ich stehe auf die Strasse. Ich bin auf die Strassteller. Ich habe da nicht die Zeit dafür und die Bücher sind ja auch nicht teuer, das sind ja uralte Dinge, die du irgendwie gebraucht für 10 Cent auf Amazon bestellen kannst, das ist ja Zeug, aber ansonsten kommt das jetzt alles weg. Ich hatte aber auch neulich meine Hochkulturphase, ich war wieder in Bayreuth. Ach herrlich, Bayreuth ist nur einmal im Jahr. Bayreuth ist nur einmal im Jahr, ja. Aber scheiss drauf, Bayreuth ist nur einmal im Jahr. Da war ich wieder bei Richard Wagner, heißt er mal ein Festspielen. Und es nie enttäuscht mich Bayreuth auf einer Unterhaltungsebene. Also so, was für Dinge passieren, was für Gestalten da rumlaufen. Es ist wirklich irre. Also es ist absolut irre, wenn man da Tannhäuser pfeifen und durch die Strasse läuft, pfeifen, also auch wenn man einen fucking Ohrwurm hat, ist gar nicht so hochgestochen gemeint, sondern wir kennen das und dann macht man das und dann pfeifen die Leute mit und sowas. Das ist super unangenehm. Und die ganze Zeit in jeder Ecke unterhält man sich und diskutiert und so.
Und ein Kumpel und ich haben uns das auch zum Thema gemacht.
Und wir nehmen dann immer auch mit und lesen was. Und dann nimmt man sich die Flasche Wein mit, setzt sich abends ins Hotel, kommt einen Tag vorher an, damit man entspannt anreisen kann und keinen Stress hat, trinkt dann abends diese Flasche Wein und dann liest man sich die Weisen nicht das Reklam-Nachwort durch zum Parsifal und so weiter. Wir haben viele coole Sachen gelesen tatsächlich, dann diskutieren wir angeregt darüber, wobei wir auch merken, dass wir Bullshit verstanden haben. Absolut. Aber es macht Spaß. Ich glaube, es macht ja auch Spaß, wenn man sich da auch ein bisschen diesem Bullshit hingibt. Man muss ja immer da, und ich glaube, das ist der Punkt, wenn du es zu ernst nimmst, dann verkrampft es auch so. Du musst einfach sagen, ja, einfach mal, hau einfach mal was aus. Aber es ist genau dieses Weinding. Viele sind ja abgeschreckt von diesem Sprech. Ich bekomme Mineralisches. Okay, langsam ins fruchtig-nussige. Und das ist natürlich für viele so ein, das ist glaube ich so, das ist die gleiche Hemmschwelle wie Opa oder wie Hegel. Weil es wirkt hochgestochen. Am Ende geht es aber bei Hegel und bei Wagner doch darum, kannst du was damit anfangen, macht's Bock, macht's ein bisschen Bock. Und die coolen Weinhändler sagen dann ja, schmeckt er dir, schmeckt er dir nicht. Und darum geht es doch. Darum kannst du reden, wie du willst. Im Kern geht es aber, hast du daran Spaß oder nicht? Und wir haben da Spaß dran. Wir waren da, hatten Spaß und dann ist es natürlich auch irgendwie ikonisch, weil dann diese böse Wagner-Büste in diesem Hotelgarten steht und wir uns da dann das vorlesen und die ganze Zeit guckt der so böse rüber. Ist natürlich irgendwie ikonografisch. Ja, aber wenn ich euch da gesehen hätte, ich hätte euch wahrscheinlich zusammengeschleppt. Auf jeden Fall.
Wenn ihr sagt, wo ist dein Wagner, ihr reicht euch jetzt das Reklam-Heft weg und werfst den Müll vor dir. Hebst doch auf und dann kriegst du immer so ein Stück weg, wenn du es versuchst. Und dann nimmst du auf hier, nimmst du auf hier. Und dann kommt deine Bulli-Freundin und du und dann ich so, nein, nein, gib's wieder, gib's wieder, gib's wieder, bitte, bitte gib's wieder. Und ich habe ja tatsächlich jetzt, ich muss ja immer noch ein Problem lösen, weil in meiner Wohnung wurde in der Nachbarwohnung vor langer Zeit eingebrochen. Und ich hatte grosse Angst, weil ich danach die Wohnung verlassen habe und dachte, okay, das ist ja eigentlich völlig irrational, aber die Angst war da. Und ich dachte, ich muss was tun. Und dann habe ich mein Gold versteckt. Dein was? Mein Gold. Habe ich mein Gold versteckt? Ichckt das damals auch im podcast wahrscheinlich mit dokumentiert weil ja ja ja ich besitze sieben gramm gold woher es war lange in meinem munde ich hatte eine zahnspange aus gold mit brackets die innen an dem an den zähähnen war. Deswegen müssen die weich sein und Gold ist ja ein recht weiches Metall und deswegen nutzt man da Gold. Und dann habe ich in diesem Panikanfall, habe ich gesagt, das hing so normalerweise an meinem Reisbrett. Und dann dachte ich, das sind so kleine Tütchen, das kann ich jetzt nicht hängen lassen, weil das ist das erste, wo man hinschaut, die Notizen, in wen ist er verknallt oder was auch immer. Uh, hat ein Autogramm von mir geschneit. Wenn daran sind die Diebe wirklich interessiert. Wo sind die Tagebücher, in wen ist er verknallt? Genau. Leute, jetzt die Sturm hauen auf, wir gehen da jetzt rein und egal, wir haben nicht viel Zeit, ihr geht straight zum Nachttisch, holt das Tagebuch und findet mir raus, in wen er verknallt ist. Go, go, go, go. Es ist Jessica, okay, gehen wir. Raus hier, raus hier, raus hier, schnell! Und dann geschnappt, dann sitzen sie im Revier und dann sagt der Officer, wir wissen, dass sie wissen, in weiner verknallt ist. Ich weiss nicht, wovon Sie reden, Chief. Sie haben die Informationen bei ihm geklaut. Wir fahren nur zufällig in der Gegend, Chief. Tss, Chief. Es gefällt Ihnen, wenn ich das sage, ne, Chief? Aber Moment mal, Sie sind ja noch gar nicht der Chief. Woher wissen Sie das? Ach, Moment mal, da gibt es ja immer noch diesen Richardson, nicht wahr? Ihr verdammter Vorgesetzter. Verdammter Vorgesetzter, Richardson. Sie könnten diese komplette Stadt aufräumen, wenn Sie nur gelassen werden, wenn sie nur mal von der Leine gelassen werden.
Aber das ist nicht mein einziges Problem. Ich bin auch unsterblich verliebt in Jessica.
In Jessica, nicht wahr?
Ja.
Sie sollten vielleicht ihre Haustür ein bisschen besser abschliessen, Chief.
Nein.
Doch, ganz zwar.
Sie wissen alles. Du bist verliebt, du bist verliebt, hinten auf dem Arm.
Informationen sind alles.
Und deswegen habe ich damals das Gold versteckt.
Kannst du jetzt sagen, nach allem, was passiert ist, wo?
Und das war das Problem, ich konnte es danach nicht mehr finden.
Es gibt ja diese Idee, könnten wir alle das FBI überlisten?
Da haben wir damals, glaube ich, auch darüber gesprochen, dieses Gedankenexperiment Büroklammer. Könntest du eine Büroklammer gut verstecken, dass wenn das FBI jetzt reinkommt, die nicht findet. Aber ist es eine besondere Büroklammer oder? Nein, einfach eine fucking Büroklammer, es gibt die Größe und das Gewicht. Und dann denkt man, man hat eine mega geile Idee und dann guckt man bei diesem Reddit-Post in die Top-Kommentare und es sind halt alles erwähnt. Also alle guten Ideen wie in einem Buch oder was auch immer. Zu anderen Büroklammern. Zu anderen Büroklammern, ja, aber es sind alles erwähnt. Es sind alles die Top-Komments. Und das FBI liest jedes fucking Reddit-Thread mit. Und jetzt bin ich gerade dabei, meine Bücher wegzuschmeissen. Ich weiss es wirklich nicht mehr. Ich weiss es wirklich nicht mehr genau, weil ich war in einem anderen Bewusstseinszustand. Ich weiss nicht mehr genau, wo es ist. Ich habe ja zwei wertvolle Dinge. Mein Kleingeldeimer, der mich jetzt stark belastet, jetzt wo ich umziehe. Ich weiss nicht, wohin mit dem fucking Kleingeldeimer. Den hast du nicht versteckt. Den habe ich in den in den wäschekorb getan ja er ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen wuchtiger aber ich dachte okay ich tue in den wäschekorb und tue ein paar alte t-shirts drauf dann ich glaube als einbrecher schaut man nicht in den wäschekorb oder einbrecher schauen nicht in den wäschekorb war das nicht sogar dein comedyprogramm 2008 einbrecher schauen nicht in den wäschekorb so hast du doch ja selber geprägt diesen spruch ja und jetzt bin ich eben dabei meine ganzen bücher rauszuschmeissen weg mit hegel weg mit schopenhauer und siehe da zwischen hegel phänomenologie des geistes und philosophie der geschichte tatsächlich gold gefunden nein gold gefunden hast dabei wie viel ist das genau wert zwei gramm drei gramm drei gramm hat man an den
mund hängen kann ich sehen hier ist es hier ist mein gold will florentin inkognito neben nicht und
da ist es jetzt will florentin inkognito circa sieben gramm ja ja wieso denn inkognito, circa sieben Gramm. Ja. Wieso denn inkognito? Das ist der Name des Produkts der Spange. Das ist Gold? Das sieht gar nicht aus wie Gold. Ich habe so eine Lucky Luke-Vorstellung von wie Gold auszusehen. Ja, so Goldbar, ne? Also das sind ja Abdrücke von meinen Zähnen. Das verstehe ich wohl. Ich finde die Farbe meine ich jetzt alleine, die Farbe. Es ist schon gülden, aber es ist eher, es sieht, also wenn man das jetzt mir zeigen würde, würde ich es auch nicht klauen. Diebe haben ja auch Selbstachtung, die wollen ja nicht die fucking Zahnabdrücke von jemandem in der Hand haben. Naja, vor allem also, wenn du das halt dann irgendwie zum Altgoldmann gibst und zu Geld machen willst, sagt er, ja, dann legen sie die mal an.
Weil die Zähne wachsen ja nicht, du hast ja noch dieselben Zahnabdrücke. Ja, ich habe mich alle gebrochen. Ach so, Sie haben sich alle gebrochen. Ja, ich bin immer auf der Fahrradstange. Wie haben Sie es geschafft, alle, jeden einzelnen Zahn zu brechen? Ich habe etwas gekauft, einen Besen, und das ist mal in die Speichen. Da ist mein Kopf genau auf den Lenker. Alle Zähne waren dann durch. Alle Zähne, auch die hinteren? Ja, alle weg. Wahnsinn. Es sind sieben Gramm Gold, ich weiss jetzt nicht genau, welche Art von Gold genau. Also es gibt hier verschiedene 333er Gold, 900er Gold, 750er, ich nehme mal was in der Mitte, ich nehme mal 750er Gold, sieben Gramm sind 380 Euro. 380 Euro habe ich nach langer Zeit wieder gefunden. Inflation, ich weiß nicht, ob der Goldpreis... Ich bin hier bei 65 pro Gramm. Ich weiß nicht, ob der Goldpreis inzwischen gestiegen ist oder nicht, also das ist schon ein paar Jährchen her, aber Gold ist zurück, das heißt I'm loaded, I'm loaded, ich bin reich, meine Damen und Herren, das Podcast-Unfuss ist loaded.
Got my cash, got my gold, got my money, got my soul, got my cash in the club, gonna drink it up.
Throw the incognito brackets in the club. Brackets. Brackets. Throw them brackets in the club. Aber ganz ehrlich, ich weiss auch nicht, was ich damit machen soll. Also ob ich da jetzt wirklich zu so einem Goldmeister hingehen kann und er sagt, ja, gebe ich ihn 100 Euro. Ja, aber also der Rechner, also deutsche-edelmetallservice.de, da habe ich es einmal abgeglichen, da stand jetzt 380 ungefähr. Ja, oder 410 Euro. Na ja, jetzt entschuldigen Sie bitte gut daher, aber also ich habe auf deutsche minus... 95. 95. Nein, jetzt gehen Sie nicht mal wieder runter. Also ich habe auf deutsche-edelmetallservice.de, da stand 380. Sie lieben Geld, ne? Machen Sie mal im Mund auf.
Ja, ich, also ich mag es schon ganz... So eine Rolle Fünfer.
Hier, es zieht
sich durch, Florentin wird von Leuten
einfach nur verarscht. Ja, also
das Gold ist da, jetzt ist natürlich
die Frage, was macht man damit, kann ich
auch was vergolden, weil
die Idee war ja, wir hatten ja eh die Idee,
eine Plakette
zu gestalten, eine Plakette an Florentins Geburtshaus. An meinem Geburtshaus, hier an unserem Studio könnte man natürlich hier Podcastaufnahme 2019 bis 2024. Und ich habe, ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass falls ein findiger Schmelzer zuhört und sagt, ich hätte Lust, diese Plakette zu machen mit, ich würde sieben Gramm Gold beisteuern. Nein, das brauchst du nicht, das ist viel zu viel. Um das zu vergolden. Ja, aber diese Plakette wird ja geklaut werden oder abgenommen werden. Und dann finde ich sieben Gramm Gold viel zu viel. Mir hat dafür, für diese Aktion, ein Kupferschmied geschrieben. Ach wirklich, genau, wir wollen eine Plakette abgießen oder wie wird das gehämmert? Das weiß ich nicht, geschmiedet, ich weiß, es wird vielleicht gegossen, ich glaube ja, eine Plakette. Wollen wir, wir kennen das von zum Beispiel das Geburtshaus von Beethoven oder Mozart oder Hegelchen. Ja, das Hegelchen. Und wir hätten gerne an unseren, wir sind ja unbedeutend, daher der Jux, daher die Juxtaposition.
Schulen.
Schule. Hier ist Florentin Will von 1998 bis 2002 zur Schule gegangen. So was sehe ich und finde mich ganz lustig. Und dann ist halt die Frage, wie lang hängt das? Und da würden wir immer wieder gucken, ob das entfernt wird einfach. Weil wer fühlt sich da zuständig? Webcam, es gibt Elektroschocker. Hängense noch de, da seht ihr dann von den vier Orten, wo wir unsere Plaketten haben, seht ihr dann die Überwachungskamera, Bild live. Und dafür wäre wichtig, wenn jemand das klaut, dann direkt so eine Hetzjagd, so eine Hexenjagd zu begehen. Ja, direkt, direkt einfallen. Weil gerade wenn du jetzt deine sieben Gramm beisteuerst, ist das einiges wert.
Ich überlege natürlich auch, ob ich das, also, wäre ich jetzt Pirat, würde ich natürlich den Schatz vergraben, aber ich überlege auch.
Wär ich ein Pirat, würde ich den Schatz vergraben, Schiffe sind so gross, würde ich den Arm reparieren,
wäre ich ein Feuerwehrmann, würde ich den Brand jetzt löschen, aber ich bin bloss ein Podcaster und liebe dich.
32 Zähne hat der Mensch, das heisst man könnte natürlich diese sieben Gramm, es sind 32 einzelne Goldstücke, die könnte man natürlich auch verteilen in ganz Deutschland und dann durch Rätsel die Leute darauf bringen, die zu finden, sodass irgendwann mein komplettes Gebiss rekonstruiert werden kann und das Gold verteilt wird. Ich habe irgendwie so einen Piratenreflex, dass ich dieses Gold vergraben will irgendwo. Es ist ein Zahn von Florentin in London aufgetaucht. Bei Angsty ist es inzwischen so bekannt, dass die dann direkt abgenommen werden. Also sie macht dann irgendwo so ein Graffiti hin und dann wird es direkt so aus der Wand geschnitten und dann wird es weggetragen.
Ach so, dass das direkt kommer abgenommen werden. Also sie macht dann irgendwo so ein Graffiti hin und dann wird es direkt so aus der Wand geschnitten und dann wird es weggetragen. Ach so, dass das direkt kommerzialisiert, als Ware in Wert gegossen, da wird direkt ein Preisschild dran geklebt. Ist es dann noch Kunst oder wird es dann erst? Was ich dir erzählen wollte, ich habe nämlich meinen Kleingeldeimer weggebracht. Schönes Gefühl, schönes Gefühl. Wir haben ja
unsere Improv-Shows.
Da bekommen wir am Ende, stellen wir einen Hut
auf und Leute geben uns auch teilweise Kleingeld.
Das habe ich lange angesammelt, weil ich das nicht
immer wegbringen wollte, weil es auch so viel, weil es
so schwer ist, nervig ist. Und dann bin ich
jetzt irgendwann damit zur Bank gegangen.
Und da habe ich mich, und dann
da bin ich aus der Haut gefahren, kurz.
Okay, weil ich gebe das ab. Weißt du, was das bedeutet, das Sprichwort?
Da wurde ich zum Bären.
Okay, da habe ich mir selbst einen Bärendienst erwiesen.
Bei Bärendienst weiss ich immer nicht, ob gut oder schlecht ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Einen Bärendienst erweisen, Bären sind doch gut.
Bären sind super, die können einiges an Dienst leisten.
So.
Du bist aus der Haut gefahren.
Du warst außer dir.
Ja, das war ein Kammeriersdelikt.
Okay.
Ja, ich glaube, okay.
Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Ja, ja, alles klar.
Können wir folgen.
Also dann gebe ich da diese Sachen ab.
Und dann war diese Frau, guckt mich an und die sagt, ja, okay.
Also nimmt dann den Eimer, füllt den um in so eine Tüte und sagt dann, sie wissen, dass sie dafür acht Euro zahlen an Gebühren und hat gesagt, so jetzt, jetzt hakt's. Nicht nur muss man Mitglied bei dieser Bank sein, wo man das abgibt, wo ich denke, nee, es sollte ein Fundsystem geben, ihr habt doch ein Interesse daran, die Inflation, weiss ja jeder, ist ja nur deswegen, weil die Leute ihr Kleingeld oder wegwerfen. So, ihr habt doch ein Interesse daran, das Geld zurückzubekommen. Wir müssen nichts Neues drucken, so einfach ist es doch. Aber das wird so wenig gewertschätzt. Es ist ein Krieg gegen Kleingeld. Man muss zu seiner eigenen Bank gehen, okay, den Part verstehe ich noch, und dann muss man bei der eigenen Bank, Sparkasse, hier werden Names gedroppt. Okay, hier halte ich nicht hinterm Berg. Wow, da wird aber gerade wirklich Gras drüber gewachsen. Das ist ein Wies erwiesen, damit das kein Kavalierste liegt mehr ist. Ja, da stehst du aber auf dem Schlauch gerade. Da stehe ich mega auf dem Schlauch und reisse den Teppich aus der Kirche, die im Dorf bleibt. Weil man muss wirklich sagen, acht Euro ist eine absolute Frechheit Ja, kommt drauf an, wie viel du einzahlst, wenn du da jetzt irgendwie hundert... Es sind immer acht Euro! Ja, eben, aber dann musst du ja viel einzahlen. Also die, also die wollen wahrscheinlich, dass man viel auf einmal einzahlt, ne, weil wenn du jetzt, aber, also mein erster Gedanke war natürlich, ich komme mit Kleingeld, das sieben Euro wert ist. Und dann gehe ich da hin und gebe das ab und die gut, das sind sieben Euro. Das macht dann ein Euro. Ich habe kein Kleingeld mehr. Ja, ich habe ihnen jetzt aber alles schon gegeben, was ich habe. Na gut, dann gebe ich den wieder. Und dann nimmst du es wieder. Und dann ist das der Trick. Dann gibst du alles wieder und dann gibst du davon ein Euro. Und das machst du so lange, bis alles weggit Und den Rest möchte ich jetzt aber abgeben. Es sind noch sechs Euro. Sechs Euro. Es fehlt noch zwei Euro. Und so kann man die Inflation bekämpfen, indem man Geld vernichtet einfach. Vielen Dank. Einfach Geld zerstört. Und das ist genau Inflation, kurz gesagt. Ja.
Ihr müsst nicht irgendwelche Wissenschafts-Podcasts hören oder sowas. Nein, man kann es auch mit alltäglichen Beispielen erklären, ganz einfach. Man kann es einfach erklären. Aber ich habe jetzt auch das riesige Problem mit dem Geldeimer und das Problem ist, das Problem bin ich selbst, wie immer, ich stehe mir selbst im Weg, denn ich hätte gerne am Ende einen grossen Zettel, wo das ganze Kleingeld aufgelistet ist. Das coolste für mich am Kleingeld abgeben ist ja, dass du so einen Zettel kriegst, wo du am Ende eine Auflistung hast, es waren so und so viele Ein-Cent-Stücke, so und so viele Zwei-Cent-Stücke. Und ich, es geht mir wirklich um dieses Objekt, nicht um das Wissen, weil dann könnte ich ja auch zehnmal zur Bank gehen und das dann selber zusammenrichten. Ich will einen Zettel haben, draufsteht so viele 120-Cent-Stücke oder was auch immer, weil es ist wirklich viel mittlerweile. Und da gerate ich an die Grenzen, weil es gibt ja diese Cash-Automaten, die haben aber auch nur ein Limit, das ich glaube ich überschreite. Auch Gebühren. Auch Gebühren, Gebühren kommst du ja nicht drum rum. Das ist so eine Scheisse, Gebühren. Ich versuche ja mittlerweile, das auch auszugeben einerseits, aber ich kriege es auch nicht hin. Ich hatte so eine starke Meinung dagegen, ich hatte so eine starke Meinung, als sie gesagt hat, acht Euro. Hab ich gesagt, das gibt's, acht Euro. Und dann war sie da so, ja, okay, was wollen sie jetzt tun? Und ich sag, ja, ja, nee, ich wollte damit das nichts abbrechen. Der Vorgang bleibt, bestehen. Ich find's aber auch richtig scheiße. Es gab mal lange diesen Gag oder das Meme, dass man bei der Landeszentralbank das Geld hinbringen kann und die nehmen pro Münze einen Cent Gebühr. Und dann ist halt die Frage, ob es das einem wert ist. Also, dass man, weil es die Frage, ob es im Endeffekt mehr oder weniger als acht Euro sind, Man kann das ja vergleichsweise leicht nachrechnen, wie viele Münzen das wären, aber machen wir jetzt mal nicht. Im Schnitt sind zehn Euro, wie viele Münzen? Unmöglich! Und das war das Ding. Und da überlegt man halt auch, okay, da wird mehr bestraft, da könnte man zum Beispiel auch nur sieben Euro hingeben. Ich bin so gemeint, diese Frage zu stellen. Aber das ist natürlich auch das Ding und mittlerweile glaube ich, geht das nicht mehr und ich war tatsächlich schon kurz davor, mir auf Amazon so eine fucking Geldsortiermaschine zu holen, weil du oft das nur in Rollen abgeben kannst und ich dachte, okay, dann opfer ich halt mal drei Tage meines ohnehin schon adipösen Lebens dafür, dass ich das da reinbinde. Aber habe ich nicht gemacht und jetzt irgendwie, ich weiß nicht. Schuss aus dem Treppenhaus. Die neue zwölfteilige Podcast-Serie von Stefan Tietze. Was geschah, was ist hier passiert? Aus der Reihe Geräusche, die die Hörerinnen und Hörer nicht hören. Da wurde jetzt letztens gelöst. Es gab so ein grosses... Der Knall von Wedding? Wir sind noch dran, Teich ist dran. Der Blob. Der Blob? Und zwar hat jemand gesagt, ich hänge mal mein Mikrofon ins Meer. Und niemand hat ihn davon abgehalten. Wie? Wo kommen wir denn da hin? Jetzt hält jeder sein Mikrofon ins Meer. Niemand hat gesagt, mach das nicht. Das muss man sofort unterbieten. Es wurde nicht unterbunden. Acht Euro Gebühr. An der Stelle, nein, keine Gebühr wieder oben. Pro Mikrofon ein Cent Gebühr. Tatsächlich nicht. Und dann hat er ein Geräusch wahrgenommen, was extrem laut und extrem tief war. Und dann kann man sich das Geräusch anhören und man denkt, holy shit, was kommt jetzt? Und das ist so ein Blasen.
Das ist halt einfach ein grosses Blub.
Ja, ein grosses Blub.
Aber es hast du aus tausenden Metern. Also das finde ich so spannend, weil die Wissenschaft, also sich Dinge zu erklären, die Welt zu erklären, nach Wundern zu suchen und zu forschen. Und am Ende ist es das, was alle vom Meer erwarten. Wenn man ein Kind fragt, ohne Forschung, ohne Leben, ohne Lebensweisheit, Erfahrung, du fragst ein Kind, wie macht das Meer, blub. Und das Meer macht blub. Es macht blub, aber wirklich so extrem laut, dass man das aus tausenden Kilometern gehört hat. Und es ist extrem tief, ein tiefes Geräusch. Ja, auch das alles hätte ich erwartet. Und es ist einfach, und man kann das nicht zuordnen. Ke keine Kreatur oder was, keine bekannte Kreatur macht ein solch lautes Geräusch.
Nein, es muss auch keine Kreatur. Ich höre auf das so irgendwie so mystisch zu mystifizieren. Und man hat lange danach gesucht, man hat lange danach gesucht.
Und Forscher haben immer mehr von ihren Mikrofonen ins Wasser gehängt.
Hört auf, Mikrofonen ins Wasser zu hängen!
Wodurch sie weniger natürlich von der Oberfläche mitbekommen haben, weswegen viele Vögel durch die Lappen gegangen sind, Kritik an der Stelle, aber Wissenschaft hat begrenzte Ressourcen, habe ich schon oft kritisiert. Und jetzt kam tatsächlich raus, die haben es immer wieder durch mehrere Messungen, haben sie es irgendwann gefunden, was dieses Geräusch erzeugt, weil sie wirklich dachten, okay, das muss irgendein Riesenwesen sein. Riesenviech. Was das erzeugt, was einfach da irgendwie mitten im Meer liegt und so da kommt so ein Mensch vorbeige und das macht einfach nur Hallo, hallo kleines Menschlein, ich bin der Blob, ich bin schon älter als ihr. Ich bin schon seit Anfang aller Zeiten hier, älter als der Baum und das Land. Es ist manchmal einsam in der Tiefe. Sag, kleines Menschlein, hast du eine Frage an den Ältesten der Alten? Ich hatte nie vor, dich zu fressen. Nein, nein, dafür ist hier viel zu wenig los. Viel lieber würde ich mit dir sprechen, kleiner Kerl wieder. Nein, bleibt doch noch eine Weile.
Gibt es keine Frage, die du mir stellen kannst, dem Ältesten der Ältesten?
Ich bin älter als die Sonne.
Blubb.
Warum kommst du nicht an Land?
Kann ich nicht.
An Land ist viel besser. Ich wurde davor gewarnt, an Land zu gehen. Nee, komm mal an Land. Okay, vielleicht sollte ich es mal versuchen. Und dann geht an Land. Und ist Godzilla und bringt alle um.
Ist Godzilla, bringt alle um und oder ist so gross, dass er so Tsunamis auslöst.
New York, tot.
Oder Unterdruck.
Tot, Unterdruck, er stirbt auch, alles stirbt, die Erde ist dann eine Art Mond, Planet, also so Krater.
Ja, das war eine der Theorien, aber jetzt hat man tatsächlich herausgefunden, woher dieses Blob kommt und es sind abbrechende Eisberge. Grosse Risse in Eisbergen und in der Antarktis. Cool, ja, dann haben wir in Bayreuth, pass auf, es geht genau so schlimm weiter. Eine Horroranekdote jagt die nächste. Dann haben wir dann natürlich in Bayreuth beim Parsich war gerade wichtig über Antisemitismus zu diskutieren. Genau, immer Thema Wagner bekennender. Leider in Bayreuth nicht so viel Thema. Achso, na gut, okay. Wir haben dann darüber diskutiert, war super interessant sehr viel gelernt viel Interviews so gelesen, super spannende Sachen gibt es darüber zu finden, googelt einfach mal, wenn ihr euch dafür interessiert. Und dann, ähm, nächsten Tag sitzen wir am Frühstückstisch in Bayreuth, wollen die Welt geniessen, das Frühstück geniessen, die Stadt geniessen, wer sitzt am Nebentisch? Alice Weidel. Das kannst du dir wirklich nicht ausdenken. Man kann natürlich viel diskutieren, aber man kann natürlich auch einfach sich umschauen. Und das war so interessant, weil natürlich sagst du, ja, Künstler und Werk muss man trennen. Aber das ist ja so interessant, du kannst es ja dann nicht mehr trennen. Also man kann über ein paar Siewald sagen, was man will. Am Ende kann man natürlich trotzdem irgendwie Werk und den Künstler, irgendwie kriegt man das schon getrennt. Geht da hin, hat eine gute Zeit mit dem Stück, mit der Musik, auch inhaltlich kann man das sicherlich von manchen problematischen Sachen lösen.
Dann sitzt aber am Nebentisch die Vorsitzende der rechtsextremen Kackpartei und man denkt sich so, Hornig, was mache ich jetzt? Und dann war die Frage auch, geht man jetzt da hin? Die ist dann vor mir zum Frühstücksbuffet gewatschelt. Horrormässig, wie ein normaler Mensch geht dir da lang? Und was macht man denn dann? Ich fand das so interessant, weil, also mein erster Impuls war zu sagen, irgendwie schämen sie sich zu sagen oder sowas. Okay, auf der anderen Seite denkst du dir natürlich auch, okay, bei der Machtübernahme werde ich wahrscheinlich keine Schwierigkeiten kriegen. Also, was mache ich jetzt strategisch? Und dann, ja, und dann ist man natürlich auch irgendwie sehr öflich und angst vor Konfrontationen, dann ist die Frage, was bringt das überhaupt, was zu sagen. Dann muss man aber auch sagen, wenn das ist, normalisiert sie ja auch in ihrem ganzen Vorhaben, wenn alle die Presse halten und nicht zu ihr gehen, sondern das, weiss ich nicht, sich darüber ärgern, still und heimlich. Also gelebte Demokratie wäre ja, wirklich zu ihr zu gehen und ihr ein paar Sachen zu sagen, kann man auch höflich. Aber dann ist sie da privat, das ist alles, ich fand das ganz merkwürdig, plus vor dem Hintergrund diese ganzen Diskussionen und dann kann man eben Werk und Autor nicht trennen, weil du kannst dann nämlich nicht zu ihr sagen, ah, Wagner hätte sie hier nicht gewollt. Kann man nicht und sie so, really? Wirklich? Ja, und das ist so, ich fand das so ein interessantes Dilemma. Naja, was wir dann gemacht haben, ist, wir haben uns beim Hotel beschwert. Okay, wow. Ja, ja gut, aber immerhin. Ich weiß, aber ich, was will man machen? Nicht ganz Sophie Scholl, aber schon, naja, mal gucken. Wir haben uns dann beim Hotel beschwert. Ob das für Sankt Stephan reicht, weiß ich nicht. Nee, das reicht wirklich nicht für Sankt Stephan, wir waren sehr überrumpelt davon. Und dann beim Hotel beschwert, dass es sehr unangenehm ist, sich mit Nazis das Hotel teilen zu müssen, das Dach teilen zu müssen. Und dann hat sie natürlich so eine sehr junge Rezeptionistin getroffen, in dem Fall, die da wahrscheinlich nichts für kann. Nicht so wie ihre Hotelbosse oder was auch immer. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ich schreibe mir das auf und dann haben wir aber gesehen was sie sich aufgeschrieben hat unsere zimmernummer nur drei nummern aufgeschrieben und wir so okay naja wir haben es versucht wir sind die topdemokraten und dann nichts wie weg tschüss bei reu, ciao, ciao. Naja, oder, da habe ich dann gedacht, vielleicht haben sie sehr viele Beschwerden bekommen und sie hat unsere Zimmernummer auf den Alisweidel Beschwerdezettel geschrieben. Ach so, okay, ja, oder ihr steht jetzt halt auf der Liste, ne? Das habe ich nämlich, das habe ich erst gedacht. Weil nach Machtübernahme seid die Ersten, wo dann die Polizei klopft und so. Okay, Tiese, wie wirze, ja, okay. Ach, Hotel Nummer drei nach achtzehn. Oh, und ihm gefällt das nicht, weil, ah, mhm, Nazi, okay, gut. Bei Parzival haben sie aber geklatscht. Danke schön. Ich muss ja noch abwägen. Ist da jetzt einer von uns oder nicht? Schwierig. Wie laut klatscht man beim Parzival? Ach, schwierig, ey. Ja, richtig schwierige Situation. Aber ich mag, wie die Realität eure Diskussion beantwortet. Man kann da so ganz erhaben diskutieren über Antisemitismus und Künstler. Was hättest du gemacht dann? Und dann kommt einfach so, guten Tag die Herren. Ja. Ach scheisse, oh Gott, okay. Das war eine grandiosere Aufführung gestern, also ich war wirklich außer mir. Und dann redet man die ganze Zeit so, wie würden wir, ah, wir sind, man setzt sich auseinander und man, gelebte Demokratie und dann plötzlich, ah, hallo Herr Hitler, grüß Gott, grüß Gott und man sagt nichts. Ja, aber es ist natürlich auch so, dass kann man, ist das jetzt der, also ist jetzt ein Faustkampf zwischen Demokratie und Faschismus, kann das so gelöst werden, wenn jetzt einfach, wenn man sagt einfach Faustkampf jetzt., kann sich zwei Waffen auswählen und Stefan Tietze kämpft gegen Alice Weidel, einfach, man kämpft hartgekochte Eier auf der einen Seite, Shrimps auf der anderen Seite, Arena, Frühstücksbefehl, ja, man sagt einfach, okay, wir kämpfen jetzt einfach und entscheiden Deutschlands Schicksal hier am Frühstücksbefehl. Meine Chancen schätze ich als nicht so gut ein. Hahaha. Okay. Sie macht einen aggressiven Eindruck. Aggressiv im Sinne von kräftig oder wendig oder eher fiesen Kampfstil? Fierce. Sie hat so sehr fokussierte, feindselige, es kann dieser ganze Rechtsextremismus sein, der aus dir raus blärrt, aus allen Poren, aber sie hat diesen fiesen Blick schon. Okay. Und ich nicht. Und dann stehe ich daneben und ich hätte so Brötchen in der Hand. Wie so Tecken, stell dir so ein Tecken vor, so eine Pixel-Stefan und Pixel-Alice-Weidel. Und ich habe so zwei Brötchen und meine Geheimwaffe ist der Resreklambüsschen, das ich auf sie werfen kann. Und sie hat so eine Bazooka auf der Schulter. Stefan wendet Rotweinlaune an. Es ist nicht sehr effektiv. Aber das wäre natürlich eine Schlagzeile gewesen. Stefan, Flucht. Erbärmlicher Podcaster verliert Faustkampf gegen Alice Weidel. Ich habe auch in Schlagzeilen gedacht. Ja. Erbärmlicher Podcaster verliert dann Faustk. Schwächlicher, angetrunkener Podcaster, erholt sich vier Knochenbrüche, nachauseinander siehst du mit Alice Weide. Ich stimme dich vor, wie du so, du sitzt so in deinem Garten mit der Zeitung offen und hast so einen Tee in der Hand, trinkst und schüttelst nur langsam den Kopf, während du die Zeitung liest und denkst dich, es kann nicht wahr sein. Aber ich frage jetzt, was hättest du gemacht? Weil wie, was es ist so krass, wie alles in einem kämpft miteinander, wie man erzogen wurde zur Höflichkeit und dann kämpft miteinander zu was, weil es ist ja so, das war ja meine Chance. Ja, es gibt viele Leute, die würden alles dafür geben, in der Zeit zurückzureisen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob ihr Zeitreisende gesehen habt, die Wagner-Festspiele der Leute rausgenommen haben. Ja, klar, es sind so ein paar Portale aufgeploppt. Ach wirklich, und haben ein paar einzelne Leute ausgeschaltet. Ja, klar. Interessant, dass die dann immer bei Wagner, dass die sagen, komm, dann fahren wir direkt zu den Wagner-Festspielen. Nee, Werk und Autor muss man tränen. Und also viele Leute würden vielleicht einiges dafür geben, mal so nah am Bösen zu sein. Und du hast es auch ohne Zeitreise nicht wahrgenommen, aber ja, schwierig. Ich hätte halt geguckt, dass ich hier zumindest die halbgekochten Eier weg esse oder so. Das habe ich gemacht, ja. Also dass man da irgendwie das Rührei weg isst. Das Rührei wurde ihr ordentlich weggegessen. Das ist die Speerspitze des Antifaschismus, wenn du einfach
sagst, alle Croissants, oder alles mal so
andetzen, alle Croissants mal so
andrücken. Ich hätte also die Speerspitze des
Antisemitismus und Antirechtsextremismus
wäre gewesen,
sie anzugucken,
zu sagen, morgen Frau Weidel,
das letzte Croissant zu nehmen,
anzulecken und wieder zurückzulegen.
Und sagen, schönen Tag noch. Und dann Partei aufgelöst, Welt in Ordnung, Klimawandel ist nicht so schlimm. Frau Weidel, Frau Weidel, Friedrichsen vom Spiegel, wieso haben Sie sich entschieden, die Partei aufzulösen und ihre komplette Ideologie zu vertreten? Das war nicht mehr haltbar, dieser junge Mann hat mir den Spiegel vorgehalten. Wie hat er das getan? Wer war das? Also mit dem Croissant, das er als französischen Wurfstern eingesetzt hat. Und ich habe noch mal nachgedacht und eigentlich diese Musik, sie ist in ihrem Kern so menschlich, dass ich gesagt habe, ich schmeiss hin. Ich möchte hiermit als Sankt Stephan ein Wunder zurücknehmen. Ach, okay, ich dachte, du dankst ab. Ich dachte gerade, du dankst ab. Während des Sprechens. Also du willst dir selber ein, also du gestehst ein, dass du hier ein Anti-Wunder vollzogen hast. Das war ein Anti-Wunder. Gut, das heißt, bisher waren wir, also man braucht zwei zum Heiligen, du hattest bisher ein Wunder und hast jetzt wieder null. Ja, weil du mir das, weil du mir manche nicht anerkannt hast, manche Wunder. Das ist ja nicht meine Schank, das ist der Vatikan. Der Vatikan hat gesagt, dass du einen Fünf-Euro-Schein durch zwei geteilt hast, das ist ein Wunder. Was soll ich denn mehr machen als Frauen Rollstühle die Treppen runterzuholen? Das ist kein Wunder, das gilt nicht als Wunder, weil es gab eine Rolltreppe und das hat der Papst auch klar gesehen. Der war in Kölle und hat sich die Treppe angeguckt und hat gesagt, da ist eine Rolltreppe, man muss da niemanden runter tragen. Deswegen würde ich sagen, das gültet nicht. Also bist du aktuell, warst du lange auf plus eins, jetzt bist du wieder auf null, wenn du dir selber ein Wunder abziehst. Ja, ich ziehe mir Wunder ab, weil, ja, andererseits, schwierige Situation. Da ist man als Demokrat, muss man sich wirklich hinterfragen. Hätte man da einfach, also du bist jetzt auch leider im Kampfsport nicht so bewandert, dass du sie jetzt so über die Schulter werfen könntest oder irgendwie zumindest ein Suplex oder so ein Handkantenschlag. Ich würde so einfach so mit der Karatehand so in den Kehlkopf. Aha. Aber dann, und dann? Ja, oder vergiften halt.
Also wenn du am Frühstücksbuffet, und das wäre dann so ein Kirby Enthusiasm, du vergiftest dann irgendwie den, was essen gerne Rechtsradikale, was, welches, was am Frühstücksbuffet, den brauner Bär, den ... Ja, Nutella, das braun. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Was essen die gern? Zum Beispiel ... Wie essen die ihr Rührei. Geschüttelt, nicht gerührt. Gerne. Die sind beim ... Gut, regional, deutsche, deutsche Eier. Ja. Braune, braune deutsche Eier. Eben. Gut. Ja, und dann, solange so saß da und dann war es schon 14 Uhr. Und dann war es schon vorbei.
Und dann, wir machen dir das Buffet zu. Aber dass du das Essen vergiftest, von dem du denkst, das würde sie essen und dann isst es aber jemand anders. Der Dirigent Christian Thiedemann kommt vorbei, locker lässig, stopft sich das rein. Als sie alle Zweifel haben, was diese ganze Diskussion angeht. Und dann hast du Christian Tillemann vergiftet und am Ende stellt sich raus, dass das dann die eigentliche Gefahr vielleicht war. So was in der Richtung. Genau. Du wirst es ja in einem Roman fassen oder du arbeitest ja schon im Roman. Ja, es ist ja Autofiktion, also viel Autofiktion. Ich werde alles noch ein bisschen grösser machen. Mit Alice Weidel am Frühstücksbuffet. Gekämpft. Da ist dann wirklich dann... In Klammern gekämpft. In Klammern gekämpft und dann wirklich auf dem Buffet und dann am Ende lag alles in Schutt und Asche. Ja, schwer, ne? Also wenn man da so konfrontiert wird, aber passt ja gut eigentlich zu unserer Diskussion. Man hält sich gerne für einen Menschen und aber was kommt am Ende bei rum und man diskutiert viel und redet viel, aber was passiert am Ende? Was kommt am Ende dann am Ende, wo ich meine ganzen Hegelbücher wegschmeisse und am Ende passiert nichts und man hat grosse Ideale, aber hier setzt man sich hin und was soll man machen? Man schlüpft sich Ideale über und dann ist man mit denen konfrontiert und jetzt am Ende schmeißt der Hegel in Müll und ich die Demokratie gleich hinterher. Und wir sprechen besser das Podcast. Das heisst, das Podcast Ufe übernimmt auch Verantwortung jetzt für den geschichtlichen Verlauf der, ja, okay. Ja, wir sind dran schuld. Okay, ja, nee, ist ja in Ordnung. Ich muss mich ja nur darauf einstellen, dass wir mit Verantwortung übernehmen, okay. Ich will nicht in die Situation kommen, dass ich im Nachhinein sagen, Leute, ihr müsst jetzt Stellung beziehen, dann lieber schon mal voreilig Stellung beziehen. Ja. Na gut., schwierige Situation, also falls ihr rückwirkend Ideen habt, oder falls ihr im Hotel arbeitet, du hast natürlich ein bisschen was gemacht, also mal gucken, was da am Ende dabei rauskommt. Ich meine, ich habe in der Zeit gar nichts gemacht. Ich habe in der Zeit, ich stand in der Küche und habe mich an meinem Nicer Dicer geschnitten. Also ich habe mich geschnitten an meinem Nicer Dicer.
Es war klar, dass es passiert. Ich sollte ja, du hast mich ja gebeten, ein Protokoll zu erstatten, wie es mit meinem Nicer Dicer geht. Du erzählst ja, ich habe das Messer von Anthony Bourdain und wahre Küche, lebt mit der Handwerkskunst, schneiden, ja, der Brokkoli, den muss man entschälen. Und ich habe gesagt, nein, ich kaufe mir die Guillotine des kleinen Mannes, dem Nicer Dicer, was im Endeffekt eigentlich ein Messergitter ist. Also stellt euch vor, extrem scharfe Klingen in einem Gitter, man legt dann da irgendwie die Zwiebel drauf,
dann mit so einer großen Klappe klauft man da drauf und dann wird es da durchgedrängt und dann hat man ganz klein geteilte Zwiebel.
Ich liebe es, aber jetzt habe ich mich tatsächlich dran geschnitten, das heißt, ich habe auch meinen Daumen in ganz viele kleine Würfel geschnitten
und dann tauchen wir mal in der Notaufnahme auf und dann sag hier, ich habe hier irgendwie 18 Teile, 18 Würfel. Und dann fährst du zur Notaufnahme hoch und du siehst schon das Schild links, Notaufnahme rechts, nicer, nicer Patienten. Ja, genau. Und dann geht es rechts hoch. Also eine ganz lange Schlange. Und dann mussten die wie so ein Puzzle diese kleinen Fleischwürfelchen wieder zusammensetzen. Genau, alle zusammen. Und einen habe ich leider auf der Fahrt verloren. Deswegen habe ich jetzt in meinem Daumen leider ein Loch, ein quadratisches Loch durch so einen Goldstempel ersetzt. Einen kriegt jeder umsonst. Ich habe mir das hätte nicht geschnitten, Nister Dicer, sehr, sehr scharf, sehr, sehr schmerzhaft. Aber ich liebe das Gerät und ich, meistens gerade bei so, da sind wir wieder beim Faschismus, bei Dingen, die eigentlich nicht hoch angesehen sind. Also alle haben mich gewarnt, kauft ja auf keinen Fall Nicer Dicer, das ist eines dieser Küchengeräte, die man nie benutzt, einfach Geldverschwendung, zu schwer zu waschen. Und bei mir ist das eine Trotzreaktion. Ich sag dann, nein, der ist super, der ist toll, der hat keine negativen Seiten. und dann zwänge ich mich selber da durch und will ihn jedes mal benutzen und heisse alles daran gut, auch wenn ich mich offensichtlich selber zerstöre
langsam mit diesem Nicer Dicer
und ich will es aber forcieren
und muss alles erstmal klein schneiden und dann
nochmal durch den Nicer Dicer, aber ich bin
dran und ich liebe das Kochen an meiner Bolognese
mittlerweile, ist auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, da war ja immer noch die Einladung,
da man zu einer Bolognese-Party
Gelage eingeladen zu werden.
Wenn du dir da vom italienischen Supermarkt schön den Guanciale oder ein Pancetta holst, Speck ein bisschen anbraten, das macht nochmal besonders an. Frage, der Neisser Deisser, schneidet der alles gleich grund? Es gibt verschiedene Aufsätze, du hast verschiedene Grössen, also du kannst es auch nur vierteln oder ein Schachbrett mässig, aber tatsächlich habe ich noch nicht alle benutzt.
Aber es regt auch an, also ich habe jetzt wieder ein bisschen Pfeffer in meiner Küche, weil man natürlich auch sagt, ich will mal alle Aufsätze ausprobieren. Und dann kocht man absichtlich Dinge, wo man dann den Aufsatz braucht, wo man dann sagt, was ich... Lieben da Rezepte bei? Nein, nein, nein, da liegt nur ein Verband und ein Pflaster bei, wo er einfach sagt, okay, wir wissen schon, was unser Klientel ist, sich damit aufzuschneiden. Aber ja, dann wieder ein bisschen Blut im Gericht, kann es ja kaum verhindern. Ich möchte trotzdem gerne anmerken, stell doch den Hegel auf die Strasse. Ich kann auch Hegel nicht auf die Strasse stellen. Weil du weißt nicht, wo ich wohne. Das passt überhaupt nicht. Ich wohne in der Partymeile, wo Leute stockbesoffen da irgendwie dann da rumkotzend da durch die Gegend laufen. Aber so geht die Demokratie zugrunde. Als ob die jetzt sagen, ach, ich hol mir nochmal hier Hegel oder Adorno nochmal rein. Das Podcast-Ufo lässt Weidel gewähren, das steht morgen nämlich in den Zeitungen. Ja, in den Gazetten des Landes. Richtig. Das Podcast-Ufo lässt Weidel gewähren und schmeißt Hegel in den Müll. Stimmt, das ist eigentlich eine sehr düstere Folge, muss man sagen. Ehrlich gesagt, ja. Das sind wirklich keine gute Zeichen. Ja. Für mich persönlich ist es natürlich ein Ballast abwerfen, aber braucht man nicht diesen Ballast auch in der Demokratie? Ist Demokratie auch nicht ein bisschen Arbeit. Ist Demokratie am Ende nicht nur Ballast? Ja, es ist nicht nur, ja. Und geht man nicht leichtfüssiger durch die Welt? Jedenfalls habe ich dann jetzt gerade so eine, ich stelle Dinge auf die Strasse, weil ich bin auch am Ausmisten. Ich habe so viele Klamotten auf die Strasse gestellt, ne die habe ich weggebracht, tatsächlich in die Kleiderkammer. Und dann habe ich den ehemaligen Koffer, einen von mir ehemaligen Koffer auf die Strasse gestellt, ich habe sofort lebewohl gesagt. Ex-Koffer, ja. Ex-Koffer, also immer noch ein Koffer, aber ist ja nicht mehr meiner. Und Bügel, hier hat so viele Bügel. Ach. Da habe ich da Bügel reingelegt in den Koffer, das hat sich angeboten, und dann gucke ich auf die Strasse eine Stunde später und auf der ganzen Strasse verteilt liegen diese Bügel. What? Und der Koffer nirgends zu finden. Was ist da geschehen? Da hat man den Koffer genommen und ganz wütend hat man geschüttelt die Bügel rausgekommen. Wie so ein Hund kam da und schüttelt den und haut alle Bügel raus und will nur den Koffer. Wie die wilden Tiere, die nachts die Stadt übernehmen. Aber ich muss ja sagen, was hältst du denn von folgender Idee? Das habe ich jetzt letztens bei mir gesehen im Haus. Wir schenken dir Weidel den Hegel. So, ja. Dafür kenne ich jetzt aber Hegel auch nicht gut genug. Nicht damit sie jetzt noch Munition, ich weiß auch nicht genau, aber ich denke nicht. Aber was als Konzept vielleicht auch interessant ist, weil mit diesen Kisten übergibt man das ja der Allgemeinheit. Was ich auch kenne, ist, dass man es in den Hausflur stellt und dass alle, die da wohnen im Haus, alle Wohnungen, dass die da mal zugreifen können. Überdacht bleibt unter sich und da habe ich tatsächlich letztens im Flur gesehen ein paar Flaschen Bier. Und da weiß ich nicht, volle Flaschen Bier. Und da weiß ich nicht, ob das so in Ordnung ist. Also kann man da Alkoholiker ausstellen für alle? Was ist mit den Kindern, was ist mit den Hunden, den Wildschwein, die da nachts durch die Gegend streifen und dann da alkoholisiert unsere Städte theorisieren? Denkt da jemand dran? Du hast eine I am Legend Vorstellung von was nachts in deiner Strasse passiert. Ey, nachts ist einiges los. Ich bin in Berlin immer nachts joggen gewesen, da habe ich oft Füchse gesehen in der Stadt. Ich weiß, die Fuchssache. Ja, ja. Aber es ist ja nicht so schlimm da draußen, nachts, es ist nicht so schlimm da draußen. Ja, das stimmt, ja. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich mag das nicht, wenn es im Haus bleibt. Nee, du willst, dass es wirklich raus Flügel kriegt. Es soll Wurzeln haben, aber auch Flügel. Ich verstehe. Es soll wissen, wo es herkommt, aber es soll den einen Weg gehen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, es ist ja immer noch, ich habe nichts losgeworden, es ist wie, ich habe nicht richtig ausgemistet.
Also je weiter es weg ist oder man nicht mehr weiss, wo es ist, desto besser finde ich das. Ich will ja auch ein befreites Gefühl haben. Es ist weg, weg von der Brust habe ich diese Klamotten und DVDs.
Hier haben wir die ganzen DVDs hingestellt, Argo war ja dann irgendwann weg, jetzt habe ich meine ganzen DVDs, da hatte ich kurz Angst, dass ich mich alte Schulaufführungen noch reingelegt habe. Richtig, die habe ich jetzt auch gefunden bei mir, ein paar alte Biedermann und die Brandstifter, der nackte Wahnsinn. So, das ist doch mal Patreon-Content. Ja, ja, ja. Ich habe leider kein DVD-Laufwerk, aber ... Genau. Aber Seinfeld habe ich nicht auf die Strasse gestellt, das war mir wichtig. Seinfeld ist das einzige, die Box ist noch das einzige Überbleibsel. Sonst, DVDs lebewohl. DVDs generell, genau wie CDs, Kassetten. Ich habe DVDs immer weiter reduziert, ich habe irgendwann alle Packungen weggeschmissen und habe wirklich nur noch die Scheibe. In diesen Büchern, in diesen Büchern. Nee, ich habe dann halt so, wo man so leere DVDs bestellt, dieser Spiess, dieser Drehspiess. Rolling Spiess. Dieser Rolling Spiess. Und da habe ich jetzt immer mehr aussortiert, werde ich jetzt auch alle wegschmeissen. Und ein paar habe ich noch übrig. Und zwar, was ich gerne mag, sind wirklich so schäbige DVDs. Also jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, einem Legend. Hostel 2. Nee, sondern so, also ich habe eine DVD, The Unauthorized Biography of J.K. Rowling. Die nächste kontroverse Person, Alice Weidel hier in dieser Schicksalsfolge heute hier. Ich habe diese Folge. Wie schrecklich. Und da, als ich die DVD damals vor langer Zeit im grossen Harry Potter Hype irgendwie gesehen habe, dachte, ich muss die kaufen, allein wegen des Wortes Unauthorized. Und es ist letztens einfach ein Typ, der ihre Nachbarn interviewt. Also jemand, der irgendwie wusste, wo Jacky Rowling wohnt und die Nachbarn interviewt. Aber warum muss man das denn autorisieren? Wahrscheinlich, weil man irgendwie Biografie draufschreiben will oder so, keine Ahnung, oder weil es sich vielleicht auch aktiv dagegen vorgegangen ist wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie ein bisschen wie Und irgendwie finde ich das, dieser absolut schamlose Cash Grab. Findet ihr auch bei patreon.com das Podcast-Uvo. Ich finde es lustig, wenn wir das neue Kino-TO werden. Ja, genau. Ey, für ein paar Euro im Club könnt ihr da auch einfach Need for Speed 1 bis 18 anglotzen. Ich gucke auch immer, wenn ich im ICE kein Internet habe, also jedes Mal, gucke ich mir immer, oh, ich weiß, ich weiß. Wow, Meinungen auf dem Gleis? Meinungen wird aufs Gle wird hier Haus geballert, Meinung wird aufs Gleis
gestellt, Achtung, Meinung auf
dem Gleis, China-Ersatzverkehr,
los geht's, ich schaue mich immer
in Folge Seinfeld, weil du mir die mal gerippt hast.
Ja, hab ich auch gerippt.
Jetzt ist ja auch die Straftaten auf dem, auch noch
auf dem Gleis, aber die gucke ich dann immer
gerne an und
das wäre ja auch geil, wenn du die
alle bei Patrick hochladen könntest,
einfach Seinfeld,
alle Staffeln, weil
Und dann habe ich noch Daniel der Zauberer, diesen kontroversen Trash-Film von Daniel Kühlberg, auch kontrovers, auch Dark tatsächlich heute, die Darker Timeline, aber den habe ich tatsächlich auch ganz gern in mein Herz geschlossen, diesen Film, weil das Trash ist, den man sich heute nicht mehr gut anguckt hat. Deutsche The Room
eigentlich. Deutsche The Room auf jeden Fall
und natürlich auch sehr tragische Geschichte,
auch jetzt nochmal mit dem, da kam eine Podcast-Serie
rund
um diese ganze Geschichte
nochmal raus, sehr, sehr berührend
und sehr, sehr traurig auch auf jeden Fall,
ja, diese ganze Ära
und deswegen, das sind am Ende eines Cineastenlebens die DVDs, die üblich bleiben. The Unauthorized Biography of Jacky Rowling, Daniel der Zauberer. Und Argo. Und Argo, der Film, der bleibt, ein Fels in der cineastischen Brandung. Es ist einfach ein Film, der ist da. Argo wird nicht genommen, Argo bleibt, Argo können, können wir da nichts mit anfangen. Die Frage war, wir sind immer noch nicht hintergekommen, weil es kein schlechter Film ist. Es ist ja so, wenn du dir einen Fernseher kaufst beim Mediamarkt und du steckst ihn bei dir zu Hause einfach an Strom und machst ihn an, dann läuft Argo. So, und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass deine DVD drin wäre, sondern es ist so ein Default-Content, der läuft einfach, wenn du es anschließt. Wenn du bei der Radiofrequenz irgendeine Radiofrequenz nimmst, die keinen Radiosender benutzt hat, gekauft hat, läuft Argo. Also das scheint ein kosmisches Grundrauschen zu sein, dass überall als Default einfach Argo läuft. So wie du ja bei Fernsehen diese Schwarz-Weiss-Gebritzel hast. Ja, ja. Das ist ja auch einfach so Rauschen. Genau. Das ist halt am Ende Argo. Was will uns das Universum damit sagen? Nee, genau. Man hat ja auch diese Urknallrauschen aufgenommen. Dann hat man das mal in eine MP3 konvertiert. Und dann war es tatsächlich Argo auf Französisch aber. Ach, das ist ja spannend, ja. Das war verwirrend, da ist einfach was schiefgegangen. Aber generell hat man ja auch Argo ins Weltall geschickt, also auf einer goldenen Schallplatte hat man den Film Argo. Als Aufnahme, Tonaufnahme und Blu-Ray und HD-DVD, man weiss ja nicht, was bei Aliens sich durchgesetzt hat. Ich bin auch so lustig, dass bei Blu-Ray, also das war so komisch diese Zeit, weil DVD war ja so klar, DVD. Ich weiß auch nicht warum, aber das war so das klare Medium. Ja, genau. Und dann kam Blu-Ray, ich finde auch Bluetooth, das ist alles so, was ist die Farbe? So blau, ja. Es klingt wie so eine 80er Jahre Vorstellung von der Zukunft. Ja, ja, genau, alles ist blau, lila. Ja, ja, blau, weisse, Inselwelt, alles Traum, blau. Aber ich finde es so bescheuert, Bluetooth und so und Blu-Ray. Es sind aber beides die letzten Vertreter ihrer jeweiligen Medien, immer noch. Ja, es ist die Farbe, die sich durchgesetzt hat. Bluetooth wird immer noch benutzt und Blu-Ray, ja, ist das der letzte Datenträger gewesen. Wenn du, wenn kein Bluetooth-Gerät im Umkreis ist, also du hast zum Beispiel das Bluetooth-Kopfhörer und es ist kein Gerät im Umkreis und du schaltest es an und suchst nach Blu-ray, findet er irgendwann Argo und du hörst Argo auf den Kopfhörern. Und tatsächlich jetzt, ich habe ja diese Geschichte verfolgt mit dieser Antarktis, mit diesem grossen Blob, was am Innenriss im Eis war, wenn man sich diese Tonspur mal genau anguckt und da wirklich das auch von der Beschleunigung hier so ungefähr angleicht,
dann ist es einmal Argo komplett. In diesem einen Blub ist der komplette Film Argo tatsächlich drin. Das ist ganz spannend. Regie auch Ben Affleck. Ja, Ben hat da tatsächlich relativ viel reingesteckt in diesen Filmen und basiert ja auf einer wahren Geschichte. Und die wahre Geschichte ist ja, dass damals mit dem Drehen des Films Argo Leute gerettet werden konnten aus der iranischen Botschaft. Die haben gesagt, wir drehen Argo und dabei ist ja der Film entstanden. Also die Dreharbeiten zu Argo, die haben sich ja als Filmteam getarnt, haben aber trotzdem den Film gedreht, haben den Film Argo gedreht und konnten aber während des Filmes da die Geiseln aus der iranischen Botschaft tatsächlich, das war eine unglaubliche Geschichte, ganz klasse. Und deswegen, wir sagen, kein schlechter Film, hat bei der Oscarverlangen 2013 auch deswegen drei Academy Awards gewonnen, bester Film, bestes Drehbuch, bester Schnitt. Und das kann ich auch unterstreichen. Ja, was tatsächlich natürlich auch Probleme bereitet hat mit der generellen Kommunikation mit dem Iran. Und soweit ich weiss, gibt es im Iran immer noch ein Embargo auf Argo. Argo. Ein Embargo. Dass sie das nicht tatsächlich vermarkten und anschauen dürfen. Der läuft da nicht im Fernsehen. Der darf da nicht im Fernsehen laufen,
was schwierig ist,
weil wie gesagt, jedes Gerät
läuft erstmal über Argo.
Die iranische Regierung ist quasi hauptsächlich damit
zu tun, da immer andere Filme
draufzuspielen. Die haben sich dann für einen anderen Film
entschieden. Casper. Casper, genau.
Im Iran. Ich habe das Gefühl, in der letzten Folge
ist es ein bisschen zu kurz gekommen, dass man bei der Stadt
Anträge einreichen kann. Deswegen sei an dieser Stelle nochmal gesagt. Was hast du diese Woche eingreift? Naja, ich habe überlegt, also, weil bei mir wird in der Nähe die ganze Zeit ein Platz als Hunderunde benutzt. Und deswegen habe ich da, wir haben kein Outro, wir haben kein Outro, ich verstehe nicht, was du da summst. Nein, du hörst das auch? Nee, ich hör nichts. Ich hör dich summen, ja, aber es ist ja kein Outro, sagst du gleich.
Ich glaube, es wird da auch, da ist es Argo.
Nein, ich glaube, es ist nicht Argo. Wie geht der Soundtrack von Argo?
Nee, im Ernst, wie geht der Soundtrack von Argo?
Mal herausgefunden, dass weisses Rauschen nur der Soundtrack von Argo ist. Bappadum da dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dumpe dum Und so weiter und so fort.
Ich habe nie so einen enttäuschten Blick von dir gesehen, einfach.
Das ist es.
Ah, okay.
So, und dann, ja, so ein Agility-Parcours auch, wenn Fix für Hunde, ein Hundespielplatz.
Okay, versteht ihr das?
Ja, wir haben kein Intro, wir haben kein Intro, alle jetzt alle. Wir wünschen euch eine ganz, ganz tolle Woche, haut rein, mögt, ich hoffe, dass euer Kampf gegen den Faschismus erfolgreicher ist als der von Stefan. Ja, und ich hoffe, dass eure Reise, eure literarische Reise besser ist als die von fucking fuck Florentin, weil, ne, also es ist nicht nur ich. Könnte die letzte Folge gewesen sein, mal gucken, wie wir das gleich noch werden. Wir können das nicht überleben. Aber ansonsten habt noch eine schöne Woche, haut da ein. Und schaut auf Patreon vorbei, wo ihr nicht nur unsere Folge als Video findet, sondern auch die ganze Serie Seinfeld, sowohl das als auch den Film.